you
you
driveclub is a very socially connected
racial experience and we're trying to
separate ourselves from everyone else by
making it making it a collaborative
experience it's not just about you and
trying to be first never erased it's
about driving to your own strengths
using your own skills and then
collaborating with clubs that share in
the rewards with PlayStation 4 when we
set out in the early days we really
wanted to make everything dynamic in
there so we wanted this unconstrained
physical environment and it's important
to us because we want to really kind of
make use of next-generation hard work I
mean when we looked at the PlayStation 4
went when we first got hands in it and
we were like well what can we do with
this and we work to make sure that we
actually pushed it we didn't just want
to kind of go well we can do something
slightly better than ps3 no we want to
take it to the next level and so they
involve kind of you know without
capturing process of the cars and the
world and trying to bring across every
little detail we could and really push
ourselves hard to make our game stand
out first thing we added was night day
cycle that makes a really big difference
you know the difference between driving
midday and a lovely clear sky makes a
massive difference to the middle of the
night when you've only got your
headlights because the sum of our
locations are so remote there's no
street lightnings that you are just
relying on headlights alone so it just
adds a whole big variety to the gameplay
experience and also helps with the
difficulty curve as well our vehicle
artists are just insane sometimes the
lens they go through to make sure that
every little detail from the correct
material or whether it's suede carbon
fiber plastic or whatever it may be
everything's correct in terms of how it
looks we've been given effectively the
budget to build the caster's of the ER
because of the PlayStation 4 you know
it's got the power to allow us to have
12 these cars in full detail all the
time resting around the AI system
essentially applies the relevant inputs
to drive the course it's a very
realistic simulation that means there
isn't any kind of magic fudge factors
going on it's not hand of God pushing
the car around the track
it's all completely plausible and then
there's a strategic layer that the guys
have built on top of that that's that
kind of opportunistic racing where if
it's a car like the McLaren p1 with
occurs and DRS systems at its disposal
it'll leverage that to the best of its
ability to jump into the little gaps to
scoot round a kind of hapless opponent
it's not that kind of sterile rating
yeah as with everything in drag but we
try to keep it as dynamic as changeable
as possible we repeat the experience for
challenges and for special tour modes
and things like that but generally if
you're just go in and play it will be
different every time so you'll get the
option to say oh I want a stormy sky and
I want it to rain that will be will be
completely up to the seeded system in
the background so it's a random system
and it's a variation on a theme but
you'll always get something different
every time even if you go in with the
same settings we really wanted to kind
of make these wells feel alive and also
that every race that you play every
every lap that you do in time trial it
feels different it kind of keeps it
alive and makes it for like a living
breathing world but also brings new
challenges to gameplay as well so to try
and enhance the the racing experience
for people who do either go out ahead of
the pack or get left at the back of the
pack we have the the faceoffs and the
ghost elements in game it'll try and
pick someone from either your friends
list or someone who's roughly the same
sort of level as you somewhere in the
world and give you a challenge to be so
it doesn't matter if you're back at the
pack you've still got drifting scores
you can be or top speed or average speed
or cornering all those sort of things to
do to keep it going and they all feed
back into your fame as well so even if
you finish last you can still get a
reasonable famous school and to help
boost yours club and your own private
thing yeah feynman drive club is like
the experience so it's as you perform an
action whether that's drifting grafting
overtaking
I think we've got like 20 or 30 of them
they all contribute towards your fame
and as you level up with fame you get
access to new content such as cars and
new events new liveries designs that you
can apply to your car it's effectively
like the currency of the game it's a
great way for you either individually as
a driver to show off how good you are or
as a club show off your combined efforts
to the world as well it's so satisfying
to be just tearing around these trucks
drifting knocking up Fame unlocking more
cars and it feels incredibly immersive
the first time you actually see a cloud
roll in and the wind pick up and the
trees start this way in the grass go
it's sir it's something you don't really
see is just the connected nature the
players I really hope that they they get
a great deal of satisfaction from
driveclub I'd like them to enjoy the
aesthetic of the game I'd like to enjoy
challenge of the racing I'd like them to
develop the social networks and that's
something that we did well with
motorstorm RC and so with driveclub
having the ability to reach out to your
friends and bring them into the drive
club experience or even the PlayStation
experience we're not trying to create a
simulation on an arcade game something
that sits in the middle something that
is a racer for everyone you know if you
are the kind of super hardcore Grayson
you can get the most out of our hunting
model but if you're new to racing then
you still be able to pick it up play it
and have fun
close Benson